emmanuel pireyre bonjour vous êtes pour
ce que vous connaîtrez pas écrivains et
des poètes
le prix médicis pour feuillerie général
c'est en 2012 ça fait quoi d'ailleurs le
devant un prix littéraire c'est d'être
connu et par un jury qui est quand même
un juré difficile de faire le prix
médicis et pas le le prix le plus facile
c'était surprenant puis c'était drôle
parce que c'était assez inattendu en
fait pour ce livre qui était quand même
un vrai lieu étrange plus étrange que ce
qui est primé d'habitude quoi que le
prix me dois celle ci serait vraiment si
souvent de cd livres ils sont un peu
différents enfin des autres un peu
expérimentaux et vous tentez beaucoup
d'ailleurs d'expérience en littérature
et cela en était une
oui parce qu'il y avait une signature de
patchwork ou ensemble agglomérat
d'histoire et de réflexion qui donnait
un livre mais qui n'était pas de la
forme romanesque mais qui était donc
plutôt surprenant l'autre surprise est
pour vous dire que l'éditeur n'avait pas
du tout prévu non plus rater tous très
contents enfin il avait pris un risque
qui disais c'est la crise on dit qu'il
faut être raisonnable moi j'ai choisi de
prendre des risques
il est récompensé et le risque est très
convoité alors vous êtes en résidence en
est ici au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous est
enrayée dans nos stades
c'est assez rare et les musiciens il ya
des auteurs du terme qui sont résidence
mais un écrivain c'est assez rare qu'ils
soient comment s'est passé votre venue
ici
en fait c'est un programme de résidence
qui existent en ile-de-france qui est
tout à fait
confortable et royal est intéressant et
intelligent qui consiste à proposer à
des hauteurs de faire eux-mêmes un
projet on décide dans ce qui va l'écrire
comment ils veulent rencontrer le public
et dans quels lieux donc les lieux
peuvent être de toutes sortes ça peut
être très original ça peut être un bar
un hôpital la maison de l'abeille tout
ce qu'on veut donc moi j'ai choisi un
théâtre c'est vrai c'est original mais
moins original que certains pourquoi
théâtre alors et pourquoi celui-ci en
particulier
alors parce que d'une part moi j'écris
des livres et je mettrai très longtemps
à les écrire
winzip à toulouse orlan on ne fait pas
du tout les un an plus tôt quelque 412
ainsi le problème en 2006 je crois que
oui voilà si l'on est donc je pense que
je fais beaucoup de recherches je lis
beaucoup de choses pour construire tout
7,7
une constellation d'histoire de
réflexion et c'est à ce jeu mais très
longtemps a là aussi à digérer toutes
ces données que je lis et donc entre
temps je fais quand même d'autres choses
et entre des formes plus scénique
oui qui sont des preuves qui sont des
performances sont annoncées comme ça des
décideurs des spectacles assez simple
c'est plutôt moi qui suis la cpu n'est
pas de comédien c'est moi qui aie qui
raconte des choses aux gens qui montrent
des petits bouts de films que je réalise
l'arrivée au début on chante aussi des
chansons donc un théâtre c'est quand
même assez logique pour ça donc c'est
pour ça que vous avez choisi le théâtre
et le thème de 50 ha précisément à la
alors j'ai eu l'idée des yvelines parce
que je voulais déjà m'éloigner de paris
donc les résidences ile-de-france sur
son sur toute l'île de france
et moi je voulais travailler sur la
campagne sur la biologie de la campagne
notre rapport à la nature à la ville et
donc ça m'a semblé bien de m'éloigner de
file en gironde en passant par
versailles non non c'est la ville
nouvelle
mon idée était de parler de la campagne
et nouvelles depuis la ville noël donc
débuter au début j'ai pensé à versailles
à l'école du paysage de versailles il a
peu à peu les yvelines se sont tous
imposés
vous êtes arrivé ici il ya quelques
quelques semaines déjà
vous avez commencé à vous imprégner du
dieu comment on fait on s'imprègne
d'abord du lieu où il y en a rencontré
pas mal de gens et puis dans ce travail
de fond pour le livre et pour la
performance on a commencé à rencontrer
en fait différentes personnes qui sont
liées à mes recherches donc des
personnes très diverses qu'on a
interviewé déjà le ca pas encore été
vraiment une relation au public mais une
relation des acheteurs et wii puis aussi
c'est des données documentaires pour moi
assez diverses
donc on a compris un critique de cinéma
qui parle de rohmer ouais un
universitaire qui parle de liste et la
musique tzigane parce que je voulais
parler du rapport aux bohémiens aux roms
aux tziganes et puis des biologistes
puisque c'est aussi la biologie qui
m'intéresse donc on a rencontré un
biologiste de l'inra de jouy-en-josas
dans mon livre il va y avoir un
personnage d'homme chien donc entre
autres ce ce biologiste l'exigera
comment on fabriquait mjs comment on
fait alors là on voit déjà un peu le
spectre de vaud de vos curiosités c'est
à dire que c'est un peu comme tours
d'eau dans vos livres faire cesser des
choses comme ça qui paraissent très
parfois un peu éloignées les unes des
autres
entre liddes seul homme chien et ses
draps et vous créez comme ça un univers
donc là si je comprends mais vous savez
très bien vous allez vous je vais
j'espère quand même le découvrir c'est
qu'à moitié de décrire de d'avoir des
surprises donc parfois tout d'un coup en
suivant deux fils qui ont l'air comme ça
s'éloigne et je découvre des liens mais
je n'ai pas pensé à qui vous échapper à
des liens de départ puisque je sais
pourquoi je parle dans cette direction
mais après il y en a d'autres qui
apparaissent qui sont souvent plus
étonnant plus bizarres qui me plaisent
plus ceux ci et là je peux vous demander
pourquoi vous partez dans cette
direction pour tout un tas de choses
différentes
alors il y avait d'abord un lien à
l'horreur
parce que dans les ans parce que les
enfants qui m'entoure je me suis aperçu
qu'il lisait des livres qui étaient des
livres que je ne lisais pas quand
j'étais enfant qui n'auraient pas pu le
lire quand j'étais enfant qui sont
souvent des livres ou des livres qui
fondera de peur mais pas comme des
polars qui sont d'un autre ordre moi je
trouve le polar ça se résout à la fin
quand même on a une manière rationnelle
pense qu'un genre et l'horreur ça reste
dans quelque chose de plus plus
difficile de rester vous envie voilà
comment elles restent inquiétants donc
je suis parti comme ça sur la recherche
sur une recherche sur le rapport entre
ce qu'on pouvait faire en biologie et
les livres d'horreur d'accord voilà donc
c'est comme ça que je suis arrivé à mon
homme chiant par exemple d'accord rohmer
c'est l'extrême inverse aux conseillers
d'ex-employés d'une part il ya la ville
nouvelle donc aussi des graisses 50 ha
dans une ville nouvelle et au maire
s'est toujours intéressé aux 19e et à
filmer dans les domaines donc à soeur à
cergy
yamar de la vallée donc ça c'est des
choses que j'aime beaucoup et puis c'est
le contraire c'est à dire c'est d'aller
à la légèreté total est donc par exemple
critique qui parle de rohmer parle des
vacances avec des personnages qui disent
que la chose la plus importante du monde
c'est de savoir où aller en vacances
quelque chose que presque on ne peut pas
affirmer du tout dans la dans la société
de la crainte perpétuelle
il faudra veiller puis il ya des
inquiétudes diverses
donc ça fait comme des sas à
contrebalancera en quelque sorte
alors cette préparation la cause avait
commencé ça va aboutir probablement un
livre que vous avez commencé à écrire
ici comment ça j'ai commencé déjà à
écrire lancé depuis deux ans à peu près
tout ce qui va aboutir ici c'est une
forme de performances voilà petit
spectacle léger avec un musicien et avec
des passages film et confirmera ici et
tout ça devrait être au moins dans une
version un peu plus à peu près abouti
donné le 12 mars sera la soirée de fin
de résidence et donc il y aura d'ici là
diverses actions
menez est entre autres donc un tournage
qui aura lieu en février mais février
voilà dans le conte fera ici à saint
quentin en yvelines et il y aura des
jeux par des photos de ce tournage qui
se retrouveront dans le livre après ben
oui des photos peut-être pas de leurs
livres c'est difficile de les serrer
dans les livres de littérature romans
des images ça va vraiment c'est c'est un
peu compliqué souvent on peut le faire
blé au livre numérique
oui avec tout à fait mais je pense que
rennes forme numérique mais cette
pression mais main street est par
ailleurs ça se trouvera dans la
performance est à dire que quand je fais
les performances je parle aux gens comme
une conférence peu près normale oui sauf
que tout d'un coup je montre des images
qui peuvent être beaucoup plus bizarres
des images de fiction en fait qui
s'insère dans le réel
oui il ya un apparentement entre ce que
vous faites votre travail de travail
d'écrivain et et l'art contemporain
on pourrait dire ça oui tout à fait oui
ça a été une des écoles la mine encore
un que j'ai découvert un peut être un
peu tard parce que j'ai pas fait du tout
d'écoles d'art mais que j'ai visités je
commençais à visiter beaucoup
d'expositions dans les
2000 et c'est que c'est une loi je pense
un état d'esprit qui m'a marqué
correspondait bien à ce que je cherchais
en fait rien la société contemporaine sa
réinstallation à la conf à
l'installation de tout ça on peut dire
que c'est des conférences des
conférences ses performances au moins
c'est un peu ça alors il ya ça c'est
votre propre travail même s'il va
aboutir à cet os - 2 mars à cette
conférence de face et je veux dire des
conférences de favre résidence et puis
il ya aussi tout un travail que vous
allez faire avec
avec la population et des ateliers
d'écriture ya alors ça commence le 1er
octobre
comment des ateliers d'écriture par
exemple qu'est ce que ça vous allez
apprendre aux gens à écrire oui on va
faire des différentes séances d'écriture
au début et ensuite d'écriture qui va
vers la performance
oui je fais ça depuis longtemps en fait
dans différents cadres
je propose des consignes d'écriture des
noms de considérer ces petits des
manières d'écrire que des thèmes en fait
les thèmes sont souvent liés à
l'autobiographie on peut aller vers la
fiction aussi mais c'est toujours plus
difficile mais c'est plutôt la manière
de mettre en forme
quelque chose un souvenir un rapport au
monde et c'est plutôt dans la nuit dans
la méthode du texte que je propose des
formes en fait par exemple prendre un
certain nombre de photos et les mettre
en rapport dans un texte
donc ce sont des petits exercices cours
qui dure on écrit des textes en à peu
près 20 minutes à chaque fois on lit les
textes ensuite
et puis les exercices se succèdent comme
ça et dans la deuxième manche ural si
c'est étudié si l'atelier en tout et
vers la fin pour ceux qui suivront les
deux sessions c'est un de ses textes
j'aimerais qu'ils puissent se
transformer pour chacun en performance
qu'il aura lui-même élaborée à partir de
son texte
donc en ajoutant soit des objets soit
quelque chose d'un peu plus scénique
quoi ce que le sens où je cherchais pas
là dans cette démarche c'est quoi c'est
montrer aux gens qu'ils peuvent être
aussi des créateurs c'est c'est oui tout
le monde en fait tout le monde peut être
un créateur et tout le monde peut écrire
ça c'est ça on a du mal écrite je sais
vraiment pas beaucoup je sais pas
seulement il n'y a jamais trop de noms
il ya beaucoup de livres publiés
peut-être visé par la publication les
problèmes mais nous écrire la même
écriture cela dit qui est qui et qui est
très partagé le nombre de gens qui
voudraient oui et puis en fait du coup
il suffit voilà il ya une sorte
d'énergie des gens à écrire et parfois
une inquiétude parce que l'on n'est
qu'on n'obtient pas le résultat qu'on
veut je trouve que c'est assez simple en
lisant des lits une femme en donnant des
exemples de d'extraits de textes soient
de la littérature classique soit très
contemporaine des textes parfois un peu
inconnu
c'est assez simple de diriger les gens
pour leur permettre de trouver une voie
qui leur convient ou le texte ressemble
vraiment à quelque chose qui leur plaît
quoi sert il ya déjà sept ans vit en
fait puisque vous avez déjà un peu
commencé à faire ce genre de
les participants sont pas impressionné
d'avoir faire un écrivain imprimé leur
marque ils attendent beaucoup de vous
attendent beaucoup donné mais ça marche
toujours en fait même j'ai fait des
ateliers dans une autre résidence avec
des femmes qui apprenait le français
dans un centre social et même en ayant
une maîtrise très faible du français ça
donnait déjà par leur imaginaire ce
qu'elle avait vécu et caetera et puis
les formes que je propose est où se
donnaient toujours des beaux résultats
alors donc vous êtes ici encore comment
ce 1er octobre premier atelier jusqu'au
jusqu'au mois de mars et encore six mois
à peu près on peut on peut encore
s'inscrire aux autres ateliers donc
venir
il faut le faire entrer en fonction au
théâtre et puis octobre novembre
décembre la période des ateliers la
grande période des ateliers et qui
donnera en ce qui aboutira prêt au mois
de mars
grâce à ces un peu d'un petit bout'chou
jusqu'au bonne marche mais vous êtes là
il ya aussi le tournage et le tournage
voilà qu'elles les ont certainement des
figurants ou acteurs pourront participer
sachets mais il faut encore que je je
conçoive l'ensemble mais je pense que ce
sera aussi ouvert alors on va donner
tout des dommages anciennement pratique
sur sur notre site puis c'est aussi sur
le site du théâtre naturellement merci
infiniment bon séjour donc à saint
quentin
merci